we've got a global view of what's
happening in education
so we can take that information to
develop this
platform and then share it beyond the
jewish market
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me how are
you i'm very well thank you
i know you're extremely extremely busy
so thank you for taking the time to do
this
and you're the ceo of jewish interactive
and a non-profit organization very
successful nonprofit organization but
you're an educator at heart
a teacher of a profession and and you
have very uh
you you're very you have very you know
um your own views on education and
what needs to happen in order to improve
education and spread messages to
children around the world
and right now you're focusing on jewish
education but you're you're passionate
about the broader sense of education
and how to do that more effectively so
i'd love to to hear a little bit about
your journey and we'll start from there
and we'll and we'll talk also obviously
about
jewish interactive and what you're doing
over there
sure um so i've been a teacher for about
20 years
uh starting teaching every age group
from
little ones right through to high school
um
and i've always been really
passionate about good education and
getting the kids excited and feeli i
feel it's a really important role
and about 10 years ago i
was actually leading a school i was i
was approached by the current chief
rabbi actually in the uk to open up a
school
so i like challenges and i decided okay
i'll open up a school
um but i wanted it to be a beacon school
i wanted it to be a school that would be
a model for other
right especially jewish schools to to
look at and
we were waiting for context the when
you're saying you're a teacher for 20
years is this specifically jewish
education or
what sort of teaching do you know i i
was a qualified teacher to
general studies um and about halfway
through my career
i actually started to work in jewish
schools
and realized that actually anywhere up
to 50
of the day in a jewish school is devoted
to jewish education
but what i found fascinating was the
delivery
and actual relevancy
of the education for that 50 or 20
or 10 was just not very good the
teachers weren't always qualified or
they didn't have good resources and i
found that quite
disturbing actually that parents are
choosing to send their kids to a school
for that reason and yet the education
that was being delivered was not on
the same standard so i decided to move
being a qualified teacher into the
jewish sphere to try and up the game
and so we opened up this jewish score as
a beacon score and it was very exciting
and this was 10 years ago
more actually about 13 years ago we
started opening a school
and smart boards were just coming in
it's amazing how much things have moved
in the past
sort of 13 years but if you think back
we didn't even have iphones then like it
was like really
computers were just coming into school
and it was just at the beginning of the
technology boom you know their facebook
and
i remember those smart boards i remember
them coming in
slowly being placed in the classrooms
right
right so we because we're a new school
we had smart boards in every classroom
it was really cool but
and i had great stuff to put on it for
math and english and it came to
jewish studies and there just really
wasn't anything except for some
bad videos and i was just thinking this
is crazy like there's just no
good content for religious education
and in parallel what's going on is that
you've got the world is just going crazy
and
religious education is really about
mainly morals and
inclusivity and living good lives as
as good people you know most general
religions like that and
and yet uh the way it was being
delivered it was
in very old-fashioned sort of
paper-based worksheets which
so these kids were experiencing english
and maths in this really virtual
exciting way and
and then the religious education was
very 2d
and that for me was a really big problem
and i met this girl um who came from
south africa her name was nikki newfield
and she had this cd
that she had made about shabbat and she
put it in my computer and it was like
disney animation blew my mind i hadn't
seen anything like this before
and i was just like where have you been
on my life this is exactly what i need i
i can't even imagine listening animation
is about shabbat
yeah it was like this whole animated
disney style
amazing cd and the amazing story was
that she had created this
she wasn't an educator but she had
created the cd on bed rest
uh throughout her pregnancy she couldn't
get up and she had this idea to create
digital content and she made this cd
so she came and i didn't even watch it
like if she put it in my computer within
30 seconds i was like i love it she's
like but wait see the rest of it i
don't need to see anymore i want my
school to use this this is what we need
but why isn't it online and where's your
educational guide and where's your
lesson plans and i was just screwing her
and she was like
wow okay okay i need you to come and
work with me
and at that point i had been in
education formal education all my life
salary jobs you know i was i was
hot i was training and lecturing and
doing all sorts of things but i
i'd never thought about leaving the
security of a salary and starting
and uh starting something especially a
non-profit i had no non-profit
background at all
i didn't it was a funny story actually i
remember i
went to see um a funder
uh to potentially get office space for
jewish interactive
and she said to me so have you got a
board and i said to her what's a board
that's how green i was like i literally
did not know that thing
about what i was doing i just knew i had
this vision i knew that this is
something that needs to be done so you
know i have to say already hannah that
you know
a lot of the a lot of people that are
coming on this in the series are you
know they're
entrepreneurs investors a lot of them
coming from the tech scene and over
there you know
going to the tech scene the route is is
pretty known that you know you find a
pain point you raise money you go build
a startup now you're coming in
which i think is fascinating as 20 years
into education
and you're saying that okay while i'm
teaching general studies i'm saying that
there's this gap
in the way that you know jewish
education it doesn't necessarily
have to be jewish but in general there
is a gap that a certain segment of
education is not receiving
is is not you know getting the quality
education that it needs there's this gap
i'm going to create a school
that is going to do this better and then
you find somebody who's actually
leveraging technology to actually get
this to make this much more interactive
i just think that it's fascinating to
draw the parallel because this is pure
entrepreneurship right here
it really was i mean she basically was
almost like an investor so she had
this trust fund set up that she wanted
to devote to developing this but she
didn't have the mechanism
uh and she wanted to pilot it in england
because it was a small community and i
happened to be quite a good networker
and i was networked with all the schools
so we just gathered all i gathered i got
in contact with all the principals and
we did this release
and we did this we just released the
product
uh without even having a company so we
we basically what we did was we had this
whole day and
70 teachers turned up it was unheard of
like 70 schools
appeared and by the end of the day they
were signing checks to jewish
interactive which didn't exist
so i walked away with like six thousand
dollars in checks
and no company like wait was
were they trying to purchase the product
or to donate
so so we are almost like a social
enterprise so what we do
is we we believe in charging for
some of our products because we want to
bring in revenue sustainable revenue but
not to make a profit
any revenue that we bring in goes to the
nonprofit
um and also because the jewish market is
quite small it's not sustainable so most
technology the way that they work is
scalability
and mass consumption but even if we
reached every single jewish child in the
world it wouldn't really be profitable
so we needed to have that non-profit
element
into it but at the same time this was at
the beginning of
the technology boom which was having an
impact on education
so i began so i left my job and i
started jewish interactive
but at the same time was
very um i was i was advocating for
[Music]
different approaches in education
because
what i could see is i saw something
remarkable happen
i walked into my classroom of 30 kids
with an ipad
and it wasn't even open and it was like
beast
honey like all of a sudden i had 30 kids
around this ipad with this engagement
that i had never seen before with
anything else that i did and if you are
a passionate teacher
and you want to get something across
then you're going to use the most
effective way of doing that and for me i
could see that the levels of
concentration and engagement
on these devices was just unprecedented
i hadn't seen that before and i thought
whatever happens i have to get my head
around this if i want to get to these
kids because this is where they're at
and the issue that i then had was years
of trying to convince head teachers
and teachers that we've got to move this
it's not it's not even um
debatable it's it's not a luxury so they
perceived
technology as this luxury and and even
today you'll go into classrooms and many
classrooms are still paper paper-based
the kids are writing handing in their
results they don't get their results
to two weeks later and how does that
correlate with these kids day-to-day
experience of instant gratification
they're on multiple platforms they're
accessing huge levels of information
and yet the teaching the education
methods have not moved on
so what's happening is are you know a
lot of teachers who haven't moved on are
still
focused on delivering content and
information which is just not where the
kids don't need
to know and be delivered huge amounts of
information
anymore on rate learning what they need
to do is learn
how to access the right information they
need to learn how to collaborate
how to access and build um relationships
uh emotional intelligence all of these
other skills that are so
vital for jobs today are not being
taught
so what i did was start to i actually
made
some connections with google and apple
and we started to train
we actually had a couple of trainings in
apple headquarters
in london for all the jewish uh teachers
in in the uk and um
and google helped as well to try and
train these teachers in embedding
technology into their classroom and it's
not just about
having a computer we can see that now
with covert really quickly
really um it's been actually fascinating
for me to watch
over the past six months what's happened
because
what's happened in the past six months
i've been advocating for years
and all of a sudden education has moved
i would say more in the past six months
than it has in
in the past 20 years it's unbelievable
how
now every single teacher has had
experience with online education whether
they like it or not
some have been really successful and
some have been really frustrated and
some
children have been really successful and
some children have been really
frustrated and i think that
it's not about the tech it's not the
technology that's the problem
it's you cannot teach online in the same
way
that you've been teaching offline you
have to change the pedagogy
and so that's what i've been trying to
do
is to change people's approach to
education
and instead of just delivering
information
changing that whole um emphasis
on to allowing children to access
knowledge and learn and
be self-directed and creative um
which you know and i suppose most people
watching here who are entrepreneurs know
that these are
essential skills for entrepreneurship
such
we know any any learner in the 21st
century really
yeah and and quite frankly with this new
generation that's coming up like these
kids they're going to be graduating in
what
2025 2030 right where is the world going
to be there
how many jobs are going to be available
if these kids don't have the skills to
be creative
and to work in a global way and
and collaborate they're not going to be
employable because
all the other jobs aren't going to exist
right the jobs that
that the teachers are currently teaching
for will not be there
so unless they have experience in these
skills they're just not going to be able
to survive in the world and school is
meant to be
priming your children for survival in
the world and it's not been doing that
up till now
i think what's happened with covid is
that the world is sort of
especially the world of education is
having a having to rethink
it's being forced to rethink and it's
difficult
and it's challenging and not everyone's
getting it right but it's
necessary and uh it's it's
been a really interesting few months to
observe this going on in the world and
seeing what's working what isn't and i
i think we've definitely uh hit a
turning point i don't think there's any
going back
i think that technology and education is
here to stay and we've just got to
get our heads around it and make it work
and what uh
what's been great for me is that i've
been privileged to be in a position for
the past
sort of 10 years where i've been
gradually working with a bigger and
bigger market i now work with a global
market with schools all around the world
and so i'm able to see what works and
what doesn't and
how they're using platforms and we're
now actually building
a new platform not just for the jewish
world for
for everybody we're building an open
source platform so anybody can use it
and the idea of this platform is um
for teachers to create content um
and children to learn asynchronously
using this content
and build sort of like the sharing
community and
so we're we're we're developing this now
it's really exciting
and it's really a gift to be able to
develop this platform
during the time of covid when we've got
so many teachers who are experiencing
challenges and blockages and we're
trying to get that information and and
and then build that into what we're
creating so it's a very exciting time
for us
of course but then i have to ask so so
everything that we've talked about until
now it sounds
like it it's relevant for all subjects
in education and for all teachers and
for all students
why why is it jewish interactive because
it sounds like
even that experience of having that
person come in with a cd and
and sharing those lessons about shabbat
in an interactive way it sounds like
that there is a
the the pain point and the solution she
uncovered
is something that's relevant for many
many other fields right so
so why why specifically in that market
because you're starting off by also
saying that
you know inherently the jewish education
market is so small that you had to
position this as an ngo
why not take this to a profitable to a
for-profit company that is
trying to help a all education all
around
it's a really good question uh there's a
few few reasons for that
first of all the jewish
market needs specific content
um and what's very difficult about the
jewish market is there's a saying that
if you have two jews you have three
opinions
right so the same with all the schools
every school is unique so everyone says
why don't you just do like one
curriculum on judaism and then you've
got it
right and there's been many many people
that have made online curriculums about
judaism so why
do we need to do it and the answer is
that
every school has their unique their usp
so to speak and every school has their
own way of delivering
that form of education and that's what
makes the school unique and that's why
people are sending their kids that
school
so what we did was we developed a
platform that allows people to create
their own content that's personalized to
them now that
is relevant to everybody you're right
but
someone needed to do it for the jewish
market and because it wasn't profitable
who's going to do that if you want to
if you want to start a business and make
it profitable you're not going to do
something for the jewish market
but unless we we actually consciously
did it
there wouldn't be anyone doing that so i
had a decision
to make i could either build a
profitable
business if i wanted to build a
profitable business
i would have to not focus on the jewish
content
to make it profitable and i
did i just decided that i didn't want to
do that i wanted to give to the jewish
world
um consciously and in order to do that i
had to make a non-profit and i wasn't
going to make profit and what's actually
amazing about
this organization is we have the most
phenomenally talented
uh people that you know have cultivated
and brought together
amazing amazing team members and they
all feel the same way they're all doing
this out of a social conscious need
for the jewish world and they're very
talented all of them could work in like
google or facebook but they're doing it
because they feel there is a need
for the jewish world so if you if you
look at other markets like the islamic
market and the christian market
there are phenomenal phenomenal products
they have much bigger budgets they have
much more people
for a start and they have phenomenal
content
and the jewish world just doesn't so
i mean there are other organizations
that are doing great jobs for high
school and beyond
but there wasn't really anyone doing
something for the elementary and middle
uh school and we felt that that was
needed so it was a conscious decision to
actually
be a non-profit to fill a need in the
jewish market however
you're right what we are building now uh
the the place that we've got to now
where we're actually building our own
platform
is consciously being built for other
markets not just the jewish market we've
taken
our learning because we're quite a way a
small community there's only 5 000
jewish schools in the world
and we're working with about a thousand
of them already really
so wow you have 20 20 of the market
you're going after
we do we do and and um and because we
and
and we're in over 100 countries so we
can really see the cultural differences
and and what's happening we've got a
global view of what's happening in
education
so we can take that information to
develop this
platform and then share it beyond the
jewish market and
at that point it is possible that we
could diversify
and form a for-profit that will help the
non-profit market
but if we wouldn't have focused on the
jewish market
then there would still be this vacuum
because it isn't profitable so it's kind
of like a labor of love
at the moment it's it's it's something
that i wanted to
give to the to the jewish world and it's
not just me i wouldn't
i wouldn't be where i am today without a
phenomenal team
phenomenally talented team who are based
in four countries
and an amazing board and and phenomenal
funders and visionaries who have all
come together
to to do this thing so it's very
exciting
that's just unbelievable 20 minutes go
by way too fast but this is
inspiring kevin you're in a hundred
countries you're in a thousand schools
you're in 20
of the jewish schools i mean that's it
and and the whole story is just so
entrepreneurial it's like raw
entrepreneurship it's just a
it's very very inspiring and i wish you
best of luck thank you for being so
generous with your time
before we finish i have to ask you the
most important question which is three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
three three words i would use to
describe myself so
i think i have to say an educator
because i'm passionate about um
education
um i'll i'll use three words in one word
like pushing the boundaries i like to
push
and resilient i'm very resilient which
you have to be
running a non-profit especially in the
jewish world i think to be a teacher you
have to be resilient to run
to open a school you have to be
resilient and to run a non-profit
let alone companies you have to be
resilient china thank you very very much
continue doing good for the world and
stay safe and stay healthy my pleasure
thank you
you